a terrified man huddles in the corner
heart pounding and teeth chattering
he sees them coming towards him huge
eight-legged figures
ten feet tall at least with eight black
soulless
eyes that seem to stare hungrily at him
it's like something out of a nightmare
giant man-eating spiders
everywhere they approach the man fangs
dripping with venom
but just as they're about to strike he
vanishes
he won't be spider food today but for
this truly unlucky guy
his ordeal is far from over let's rewind
when life gets a little too boring we
all daydream about getting away
maybe you imagine sitting on a tropical
beach or
camping in the mountains and breathing
in the fresh air
some of the more adventurous types with
a vivid imagination
might daydream about visiting a parallel
universe
who wouldn't want the chance to see what
life is like in another dimension
of course it would only be fun to go
there if you could control
where you went and when you could come
back
without any control over it the ability
to hop back and forth between dimensions
would turn from a blessing
to a curse just ask scp-507
scp-507 unlike most other scps
is a seemingly normal human man he has
blonde hair
green eyes and unrecognizable accent
and no other features that might make
him stand out
he looks perfectly average like a
stranger you'd pass on the street and
never give a second thought to
what sets him apart is not a physical
attribute
but rather an ability that he has yet to
develop a firm grasp on
he is a dimension hopper with no control
over where he goes or when he'll get
back
after appearing on the grounds of a
mental treatment facility with no
identification rambling about a world of
giant spiders
scp-507 was admitted to the hospital and
sedated for his own
safety he would spend several months in
treatment for a variety of supposed
disorders
but once he became aware of his
surroundings he attempted to escape the
hospital
multiple times during these escape
attempts
he often eluded hospital staff by
mysteriously disappearing and
reappearing in
seemingly impossible places such as
behind locked doors or in rooms blocked
off from the rest of the hospital
these disappearances and reappearances
seem to be
contrary to what the hospital staff
first believed
beyond his control the scp foundation
became aware of the strange phenomena
surrounding 507 and he was removed from
the hospital and brought to an scp
foundation facility once there the
nature of his abilities became much
clearer
scp-507 is able to without intent or
even knowledge that it is about to occur
shift from this reality to another
alternate reality
after some time there with the amount of
time varying from case to case
he will shift back to this reality he
has been known to shift realities while
sleeping
in the middle of a sentence and even
while bathing or going to the bathroom
the shifts are unpredictable and there
is no telling what kind of horrors he
will encounter in the new dimension
where he ends up
leading to 507 having seen some very
strange things
even by a cp foundation standards during
one of his shifts
507 found himself in a pitch black room
filled with the sound of muted breathing
using a flashlight he had been given by
the foundation he looked around and
found that he was not alone
in the room with him was a man wearing a
black suit and sunglasses
with a frightening inhumanly wide smile
the smiling man leaned in towards 507
so close that their faces nearly touched
and
said back so soon terrified 507 fired
several rounds from a foundation-issued
pistol
then curled up in the corner of the room
until he shifted back
to our reality this would not be the
last time that he encountered the
smiling man
according to document 507-3b
which details all of 507 shifts into
other realities
507 was found in a midwestern cornfield
by foundation staff with brown liquid on
his cheek
in his hand he held a human heart with
the words i need you
written on it in the same brown liquid
before he shifted back
and landed in the cornfield 507 shifted
to a pitch black room filled with the
sound of muffled crying
he turned on his flashlight taking note
of his surroundings
and found himself face to face with the
smiling man
once again the smiling man had brown
liquid leaking from around its
sunglasses
which it wiped onto 507's cheek upon
further examination
507 saw several bullet holes in the
smiling man's suit
leaking the same brown liquid he
attempted to fire his pistol like he had
the previous time
but it did not fire as the smiling man
began to approach him
507 turned and ran he ran for about 10
minutes
before finding a corner where he stayed
huddled once again
until he shifted back the smiling man is
not the only nightmare that scp-507 has
encountered on his travels
during another shift 507 described
appearing in a small room
filled with dried corpses a single
window
and a flickering light hanging from a
ceiling while attempting to wait out his
time in the room
he discovered that the corpses were
capable of movement
whenever the room was in darkness the
corpses would pose themselves like
living people
when he looked out the window the
corpses would join him and look out the
window with him
when he sat down they would sit with him
in a circle
507 attempted to pass time by falling
asleep
but was unable to do so though many of
his experiences were disturbing
only one of 507's documented shifts
resulted in him requesting a memory wipe
from the scp foundation
on this one he found himself in the
maternity wing of a large hospital
a creature dressed like a nurse
approached 507 and told him that he was
upsetting the other patients
and that it was time to start the
operation 507 was then wrapped in a
straitjacket and wheeled into an
operating room
after the straitjacket was taken off 507
grabbed a chair and swung it wildly at
the creatures to keep them at bay
until he shifted back when he asked to
describe the appearance of the nurse
creature
507 began screaming in terror and was
unable to provide a coherent description
he attempted to provide a drawing of the
creature but was only able to produce a
series of jagged lines
following this encounter his request for
a memory wipe was denied
other shifts included going to a world
where every surface was covered with an
unidentifiable mold a land of icy
tundras populated by aggressive bears
and one place that he refused to
describe
beyond repeating the phrase so many
spiders
not all of the worlds that 507 has
encountered are frightening
some are simply strange and unusual
during one shift
he found himself on a large basketball
court where six other individuals were
playing a game of basketball
there were two humans two insectoid
creatures
one creature resembling a squid and one
hovering yellow sphere with eight arms
when 507 asked where he was he was
informed that he had arrived at the all
species sports center
during another shift 507 found himself
in a world made entirely of gelatin
during yet another shift he appeared in
a large auditorium
filled with 50 000 other dimension
hoppers who were holding a political
rally
for the people's dimension hopper
republic working with the republic over
the course of two weeks
507 helped to overthrow the united
states government and establish a new
one
run by dimension hoppers scp-507 was
elected representative of massachusetts
but just before he could introduce his
first official piece of legislation
he shifted back to our reality one day
at the facility
a particularly unusual event involving
scp-500
occurred the events of which were
documented in interview 507-g
during a regular check-in it was
discovered that there were somehow two
identical versions of scp-507 in its
room
they had apparently each arrived in the
room independently
and had been talking to one another for
about half an hour before being
discovered
these two versions were referred to as
507-a
and 507-b when prompted for an
explanation
507-b explained that there were more
than one version of scp-507 afflicted
with
uncontrollable dimension hopping the
doctor inquired as to which one of the
two was the visitor
but the two declined to answer fearing
that this knowledge would cause the
foundation to view one of them
as expendable the two had multiple
shared experiences that they related to
the doctor
including both having encounters with
the smiling man
during the interview 507-b disappeared
mid-sentence
and did not reappear the doctor asked
507-8 about identifiable differences
between his
and his devil's realities 507-a
explained that in 507-8
world president lincoln was killed by
his vice president
whereas in 507-a's world he was killed
by general lee
this revelation made it clear that
neither 507-a
nor 507-b were native to this reality
after this was revealed 507-a was
terminated
and examined no biological reason for
507's ability to hop from dimension to
dimension was found
though it was discovered that several
pieces of 507 will shift dimensions
along with the rest of the body
three days after this interview was
conducted the correct scp-507 reappeared
with no knowledge of his doppelgangers
or what became of them
scp-507 is classified as safe
meaning he doesn't require any real
effort to contain
he's also safe in the more literal sense
in that he poses no threat to anyone
else
the only person in danger in the
presence of scp-507
is himself as he has been exposed to
many dangerous conditions during his
reality shifts
and it's never known whether 507's next
shift will end up being his last
with the cause of his shift still being
unknown there is nothing that the
foundation can do
to prevent them all they can do is
monitor him
and provide him with the items that
might ensure his safety in the future
like a handgun loaded with rubber
bullets a tank of air
a high intensity flashlight a week of
ration packs
a pair of binoculars a tracking collar
and a camera
the tracking collar allows the
foundation to recover 507 when he shifts
back to our reality
in a location other than the containment
facility
the rest of the equipment was granted at
his request
based on obstacles that he encountered
in other dimensions
due to his docile nature 507 is given
freedom to move about the facility
but when he leaves his private room an
agent must go with him to document any
shifts that might occur
no one is allowed to touch scp-507
though
if it has been more than two weeks since
the shift occurred
this policy stems from an incident in
which an agent who was touching 507
shoulder at the time of a shift was
taken with him
and did not return when he is not
shifting
scp-507 lives a relatively normal life
at the facility
he has allowed his own computer with
internet access
and can meet with other safe or
euclid-class scps that are not
infectious or detrimental to his health
507 has expressed an interest in the
unusual and paranormal
and has enjoyed meeting with other scps
including a request to visit
scp-082 for a vacation
so far all of these meetings have
occurred without
incident due to his anomalous shifting
scp-507 will never be able to live
a normal life unless he stops shifting
he will likely spend the rest of his
days bouncing between unknown
dimensions and his containment facility
just like so much else about him
his relationship to his special talent
is a bit of a paradox
he has the ability to go anywhere to see
things
no other person on earth has ever seen
however
because he cannot control it cannot stop
it
no matter how far away he can travel he
will never
truly be free now go check out scp-1000
bigfoot and scp-066 eric's toy for more
tragic tales from the scp
foundation